مرحباً، اسمي ديفيد براون وهذا درس في النطق. مرحباً ديفيد. أنا
بخير شكراً لك. كيف حالك؟ أنا بخير جداً. شكراً لك. شكراً لك. أهلاً بك.
شكراً لك يا ديفيد. هل أنت مستعد لدرس اليوم؟ نعم. حسناً. حسناً. إذاً يمكننا
أن نتدرب على هذا الدرس الذي أرى أنك اخترته. لدينا هذا الصوت القصير
لحرف i ثم هذا الصوت الطويل لحرف e. الصوت القصير لحرف i يشبه /ɪ/ ثم
الصوت الطويل لحرف e يشبه /iː/، أليس كذلك؟ حسناً. من المهم لنا أن نتقن هذا لأنه
يمكن أن يسبب التباساً للمتحدثين الأصليين باللغة الإنجليزية وهو حقاً
زوج من الأصوات يُخطأ في نطقه بشكل شائع. لدينا بعض الأمثلة هنا. بعض الأمثلة
المضحكة. لدينا fill و feel، و sit و seat، و chip و
cheap. هذه bit. وهذه beat, beat, ship وهذه sheep. هذه
lid وهذه lead. حسناً. إذاً نحتاج إلى معرفة الفرق بين صوت
/ɪ/ وصوت /iː/، صوت /ɪ/ وصوت /iː/. حسناً.
صوت /ɪ/ القصير مقابل صوت /iː/ الطويل. هذا ما سنتدرب عليه في درس اليوم. صوتان
مختلفان. على سبيل المثال، ما هذا؟ هذا ship*, ship، جيد جداً. وهذا،
هذه sheep. هذه sheep، أليس كذلك؟ اسم جمع منتظم. إذاً نحن
ننظر إلى صوتين في اللغة الإنجليزية قد يكونان مربكين قليلاً ولكنهما مهمان جداً جداً
للتحدث بوضوح. نريد أن نفهم وأن نُفهم وهذا يمكن أن
يؤثر على استيعابنا. لذا يمكن أن يغير معنى الكلمات. لدينا هذا
وهو ship وهذا وهو cheap وهذا مجرد مثال واحد. إذاً اليوم لدينا
هدفان هنا. أود منكم الاستماع إلى هذه الأهداف. اليوم
ستتعلمون سماع الفرق بين /ɪ/ و /iː/ وقول /ɪ/ و /iː/ بشكل أوضح. دعنا
نجرب هذا. هل يمكنك التكرار ورائي؟ /ɪ/. الآن، /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/. رائع. ولدينا نشاط صغير
هنا للتدرب. قلت إنك ستحتاج إلى شيء مثل عصا وشيء
مثل مكعب. لذا لدي قلم رصاص ملون وأحد مكعبات ابنتي. هل لديك
شيء؟ حسناً، نعم، نعم، لدي شيء. حسناً، حسناً، كهذا. حسناً، إذاً دعنا
نتخيل أن لدينا صوت /ɪ/ وهو يشبه النقر على مكعب. حسناً، أليس كذلك؟ إذاً انقر /ɪ/
على مكعبك، قل /ɪ/. الآن لدينا صوت /iː/ وهو أطول. يمكنك أن تتخيل أن لديك
قلمك وأنت تسحبه على شيء ما، /iː/, /iː/, /iː/. جيد، /iː/. حسناً، إذاً
استمع مرة أخرى، /ɪ/, /ɪ/ /iː/, /iː/. لاحظ أن فكك يتغير. لسانك يكون في وضع
أعلى في فمك لأحد الصوتين مقارنة بالآخر. الأمر كله يتعلق بوضع لسانك
في فمك، صوت /iː/ مقابل صوت /ɪ/، الذي يكون أكثر استرخاءً قليلاً. حسناً. هل تسمع
الفرق؟ نعم. حسناً، ممتاز. إذاً الـ i القصيرة، صوت /ɪ/، يختلف قليلاً
عن صوت /iː/، صوت /iː/ يكون أكثر...، وهو /iː/ مع اللسان مرفوعاً للأعلى. لدينا
صوت /ɪ/ مع الفك منخفضاً للأسفل، /iː/، أترى فمي، /iː/، حسناً؟ حسناً، الآن أنت
لا تريد أن تقول /ɛ/، وهذا هو، لدينا صوت /ɛ/ مثل في lead (معدن - maʿdin)، ولدينا صوت /ɪ/ مثل في lid،
ثم لدينا صوت /iː/ مثل في lead (يقود - yaqūd). وكل هذا يعتمد على وضع لسانك
في فمك. لدينا /ɛ/, /ɪ/, و /iː/. كرر بعدي، /ɛ/, /ɪ/, /iː/   /ɛ/, /ɪ/, /iː/
/iː/. جيد جداً. حسناً، إذاً هناك بعض الاختلافات في هذه الأصوات اعتماداً على وضع
لسانك أو فكك. لذا يجب أن يكون فمك مفتوحاً أكثر قليلاً من عند نطق حرف
الـ /i/ في الإسبانية. شفتاك مسترخيتان (mustarkhiyatān)، لا مبتسمتان ولا مشدودتان. لذا مع /ɪ/، الأمر أشبه
بهذا قليلاً وهو فقط /ɪ/, /ɪ/, أليس كذلك؟ ليس /ɛ/. اللسان مرتفع قليلاً،
إلى الأمام قليلاً، وستحتاج إلى إرخاء لسانك قليلاً. وهو صوت سريع، قصير
سريع كأنه نقرة خفيفة على المكعب، أليس كذلك؟ حسناً. اشعر به، مسترخياً. إذاً حاول
إصدار هذا الصوت بنفسك. يمكنك كتم الصوت. حاول إصدار هذا الصوت بنفسك مرة أخرى. دعني
أسمعك. حسناً، /ɪ/, /iː/ ثم /ɪ/, و /iː/, جيد جداً. ممتاز. حسناً. حسناً.
ومجرد القليل من هذا التدريب يمكن أن يحدث فرقاً كبيراً. إذاً الآن أريدك أن
تريني... يمكنك استخدام مرآة أو يمكنك استخدام الكاميرا أيضاً. إذا كنت خجولاً جداً من استخدام
الكاميرا، لا بأس إذا أردت استخدام مرآة. إذاً انظر إلى فمك في الكاميرا.
حسناً. هكذا. يمكنك رؤية /ɪ/, /ɪ/, /ɪ/, /ɪ/, ليس /ɛ/, بل /ɪ/... /ɪ/ , و /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, /iː/, مثالي.
حسناً، إذاً لديك الفم، حيث تكون الشفتان ممدودتين بشكل واسع، مثل شريط مطاطي، عند نطق
أصوات /iː/، ويكون اللسان عالياً وفي المقدمة، ويمكنك الشعور ببعض التوتر. لذا
لدينا، هذا، وهو صوت /iː/، هذا /ɪt/، وهذا /iːt/، أليس كذلك؟ صحيح.
إنه صوت طويل وممتد، مثل سحب شيء ما. لذا يمكنك أن تتخيل عند نطق صوت /iː/
أن لديك، مثل أشرطة مطاطية تسحب زاوية فمك لهذا الصوت.
إذاً يمكنك رؤية هذا في الصورة هنا. لديك أصوات /ɪ/ هنا، وهي في المنتصف
في الأمام. الفك متوسط إلى مغلق (al-fakku mutawassiṭ ilā mughlaq)، وهو مسترخٍ. ثم صوت /iː/ يكون أكثر انفراجاً (akthar infirājan).
يكون مغلقاً أكثر قليلاً، واللسان أعلى قليلاً.
عمل جيد. حسناً، إذاً لنتدرب على بعض هذه. إليكم نشاط لنا. لديك
مكعبك وقلمك الرصاص أو الحبر، أو أي شيء، أو عصا. حسناً. إذاً عندما، عندما أقول،
أو عندما، وعندما تقول كلمة تحتوي على صوت /ɪ/ القصير هذا، أريدك أن تنقر على المكعب.
حسناً. ثم عندما تحتوي على صوت /iː/ الطويل، أريدك أن تحرك عصاك. هل أنت مستعد؟
أنا مستعد. حسناً. إذاً ship. كرر، ship, ship.
أهأ. Ship. Ship. Get. Bed. Bed. Beats. Beats. Ship. Ship. و ship.
Sheep. جيد. Sit. جيد. Fill. Feel. Feel. جيد. حسناً. يمكننا التدرب أكثر قليلاً على هذا الصوت /ɪ/.
صوت /ɪ/.